did you guys know that facebook has
their own space program
nowadays it seems like every mega
billionaire has their eyes on space
zuckerberg has actually been in the
space scene for a decent amount of time
now
having started facebook space program in
but unfortunately like blue origin it
doesn't seem like zuckerberg has much to
show
after several years of work so what
happened to zuckerberg's space program
well unlike the traditional space
companies that we are used to
it doesn't seem like facebook has any
ambitions to actually build and launch a
rocket themselves
facebook is more focused on what can be
accomplished using rockets as opposed to
the rockets themselves
this focus has led to three primary
projects which are a drone-based
internet service
a satellite-based internet service and a
space probe capable of traveling
one-fifth the speed of light starting
with the drone-based internet surveys
facebook initially announced this
project in 2014
in conjunction with their new
connectivity lab the connectivity lab
was created by hiring ex-nasa and decent
employees
and the lab was tasked with working on
the internet.org project
this project was a partnership between
seven major corporations
including facebook samsung ericsson
mediatek
nokia oprah and qualcomm the goal of
their project was to bring affordable
internet access to the 5 billion people
around the world
who didn't have it at the time each
company in the partnership had a
specific role within the project
the smartphone companies had the task of
implementing special antennas into their
smartphones
that could access the new internet
service the other tech companies had a
role of improving data compression by
making it cheaper
and more efficient and facebook had the
role of designing
and launching the internet drones
themselves this internet.org project was
eerily similar to google's project loon
the only difference between the two
projects is that facebook proposed to
use drones
while google proposed to use a network
of balloons both of these solutions
sound super cool
in theory but they also seem super
impractical and
pointless why were these companies
messing with the drones and balloons
when they could just launch satellites
to provide internet service
satellites can leverage the
gravitational force of the earth to
basically infinitely orbit around the
earth with no effort from the satellite
drones on the other hand have to
constantly run their engines to maintain
altitude
while the latter option is a much more
inefficient solution it shines in two
areas which are cost
and accessibility even for spacex each
satellite ends up costing hundreds of
thousands of dollars
not to mention the cost of the rocket
launch meanwhile
flying drones will likely only cost
thousands of dollars each
if anything it might cost tens of
thousands which is still only a fraction
of the cost of launching a satellite
aside from being much cheaper the
internet service offered by the drone
network will be accessible by
significantly more devices
nowadays smartphones are the easiest and
cheapest way to access the internet
because of this entry-level internet
users especially in third world
countries
are much more likely to have a
smartphone than a computer
so providing mobile internet service is
more effective than broadband service
when trying to reach individuals with no
internet access and
here's the thing even the top flagship
phones do not have the ability to
communicate with satellites
in space so it would be foolish to think
that people in third world countries
have smartphones
that can access satellite internet
considering all of this
the reason facebook was launching drones
instead of satellites
is because drone-based internet would
provide internet that is much cheaper
and much more accessible to the lowest
tier of internet users
unfortunately though this ambition
wouldn't quite pan out
in the summer of 2016 facebook would
conduct the first flight test of their
solar powered drone
this test was actually a massive success
and was quite promising
the test flight was only supposed to
last 30 minutes but it ended up flying
for 90 minutes
now the goal was to have the drone
eventually fly 90 days at a time
but this was a great start the same
cannot be said about the landing though
a strong gust of wind combined with
software issues would lead to one of the
wings scraping on the ground
and a 20-foot section breaking off
facebook would end up correcting this
mistake
in their second test flight which nailed
the landing but
for some reason facebook would decide to
scrap the drone altogether
and shut down their manufacturing plant
in 2018. this doesn't mean that facebook
gave up on drone-based internet though
they simply ditched trying to make their
own drone instead
they would partner with airbus in
november of 2017.
since then we have heard about a couple
of test flights here and there
but aside from that there really hasn't
been many progress updates
it's assumed that the companies are
perfecting the drone and if things go
well
we could see a beta rollout within the
next couple of years
moving on we have facebook's plan with
satellite internet
this sector really needs no explanation
with satellite internet
facebook is looking to provide broadband
internet service to second tier internet
users
these people usually already have
broadband internet or at least mobile
internet
but their connection isn't the best so
facebook along with spacex
blue origin and oneweb are looking to
provide cheaper
faster and more reliable internet access
to these people
since facebook doesn't have launch
capability though they have to rely on
rocket companies to launch their
satellites
ironically one of their first satellite
launches was in conjunction with spacex
and this launch happened to be one of
spacex's
only failures since then though facebook
has successfully built up a
constellation of 53 small satellites
and they hope to launch a broadband
service in the imminent future
i'm not too sure how successful such a
service will be though
facebook will likely have a tough time
matching their prices offered by
starlink
since they don't launch their own
satellites facebook also doesn't have a
massive subscriber base that they can
leverage
for instance it looks like jeff bezos
and amazon will be late to the satellite
game
but when they do enter it looks like
they're positioned to become the second
largest satellite internet provider
not only would jeff bezos have launched
capability with blue origin
but he can also leverage his massive
prime subscriber base
i feel like people would either just go
with spacex to support their mission
or just go with amazon because it's
convenient so
i'm not quite sure why someone would
choose facebook or oneweb over the
competition
but that's just what i think let me know
if you guys disagree
anyway that brings us into facebook's
final and likely their most exciting
project called breakthrough starshot
zuckerberg founded this project in april
of 2016 with stephen hawking
and russian billionaire yuri milner the
goal of the project
is to send probes to plants with liquid
water these planets are often called
goldilocks zoned planets
the fact that the water is liquid proves
that the plant is not too cold
or too hot according to zuckerberg
planets that don't have liquid water
aren't that useful for human
inhabitation he previously wrote
mars has no water so it would be
difficult to ever live there
elon musk and his fans would likely
disagree with this notion
but it is true that terraforming mars
into an earth-like planet would take
thousands and thousands of years
zuckerberg claims that it's quite
possible the closest planet that humans
could actually live on
is orbiting alpha centauri and the only
way to know that for sure
is to visit close enough to photograph
the planet which is what this project
will do the only problem with this idea
is that alpha centauri
is 4.3 light years away or about 25
trillion miles away even if we use the
fastest spacecraft we have today
it would take 30 thousand years to get
there according to zuckerberg
but one of the main reasons for such a
long travel time is the large mass of
the spacecraft
newton's basic second law states that
force equals mass times acceleration
so if you decrease the mass
substantially you can significantly
increase acceleration
and get much closer to the speed of
light and this is precisely what
zuckerberg plans to do
advancing technology has made it
possible to manufacture extremely small
cameras
and sensors and zuckerberg wants to
build nanoprobes called nanocraft
as the name suggests a nanoprobe is an
optical device that measures as little
as just
100 nanometers in length to put that in
perspective
you could fit 100 million nanoprobes
within a single square millimeter
it's unlikely that zuckerberg's aircraft
will be that small but that gives you a
reference
as to how small nanoprobes can get given
the extremely small mass of such devices
zuckerberg is hoping to launch his
probes using a laser beam that will
launch his probes at one fifth
speed of light that's the same as 134
million miles per hour
or 60 million meters per second even at
that speed though
it's going to take quite a bit of time
to actually reach alpha centauri
zuckerberg expects that his nanocraft
can reach alpha centauri within 20 years
after launch
and once there the nanocraft should be
able to identify any signs of liquid
water
and extraterrestrial life on any of the
planets at the end of the day
it's no question that space is the next
big venue of growth
so it's not surprising that billionaires
are crowding into the space
so far zuckerberg has been working with
airbus to deploy cheap mobile internet
and rocket companies to deploy cheap
broadband internet looking forward
zuckerberg is determined to find the
closest signs of liquid water and alien
life with this nanocraft
despite the setbacks in all of these
projects zuckerberg has continued to
persist forward
but only time will tell which one of
these endeavors if any
will evolve into something much bigger
do you guys think zuckerberg has a real
chance
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys love seeing the growing
interest in the space industry
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you